Who ever thought cheese could be so dangerous?
In the high-stakes world of reality game shows,
anything can hurt!
"The Amazing Race" has steadily pitted teams
of two in competitions around the globe for
over twenty years as one of CBS' most enduring
reality game shows.
In addition to embarking on the arduous journey,
contestants are tasked with unusual challenges
to help receive bonuses and other clues.
One challenge involving watermelons explosively
backfired on a contestant.
The Season 17 debut episode of "The Amazing
Race" had contestants travel across England
before using a slingshot to fire a watermelon
at a target to receive their next clue.
After several missed attempts, contestant
Claire Champlin pulled back on the slingshot
to fire the fruity projectile at the target,
only to have it flung right back into her
face at full force.
While the watermelon shattered on impact,
Claire was cleared by medical to continue
the challenge, as encouraged by her teammate
Brook.
Even on paper, the British competition series
"The Jump" sounds like a televised disaster
in the making.
Celebrity contestants are trained by mentors
to compete in various winter sports, including
a large ski jump.
This potentially perilous premise was put
to the test during the show's third season
in 2016, which featured a stunning number
of painful injuries that resulted in several
contestants withdrawing prematurely throughout
the season.
The withdrawals began early on, with contestant
Tina Hobley leaving the show after dislocating
her elbow while training for the ski jump.
She was followed by Rebecca Adlington, who
left after dislocating her shoulder while
training for an air jump.
These events were followed by incidents occurring
to contestants Beth Tweddle, who suffered
a spinal injury; Mark-Francis Vandelli, who
broke one of his ankles; and Linford Christie,
who endured a hamstring injury.
Despite all the accidents, "The Jump" returned
for one additional season the following year,
which saw its own set of contestant injuries.
While "Dancing on Ice" is also a British competition
series featuring celebrity contestants and
winter sports, it has a much less hazardous
premise than "The Jump."
"Dancing on Ice" pairs contestants with figure
skating mentors, and the duos carry out elaborate
routines each episode as they are steadily
eliminated based on the judges' scores.
British actor Jennifer Ellison was paired
with figure skating mentor Daniel Whiston
for the seventh season before a bloody incident
occurred.
While performing a routine set to Peggy Lee's
"Fever," the actor accidentally kicked herself
in the back of the head with her ice skate's
blade.
"Well, um, we can see that, uh, Jen has actually
hurt her head."
Though Ellison admirably managed to finish
her set despite bleeding profusely from her
scalp, the duo were eventually eliminated
by the season's penultimate episode.
There is something about British reality competition
shows putting their celebrity contestants
in uncomfortable positions.
This is especially true for "I'm a Celebrity...
Get Me Out of Here."
The series' tenth season in 2010 put its cast
in the untamed Australian wilderness, where
the contestants underwent challenges as they
endured the rigors of the jungle together.
This resulted in contestants Shaun Ryder and
Lembit Opik having their own harrowing experiences
at the fangs of the local wildlife.
One of the season's challenges had the contestants
forage through a set of boxes in search of
a key, with several containing rats and one
housing a python.
Both Ryder and Opik were bitten by the python
and required immediate medical attention.
Fortunately for the Happy Mondays frontman,
Ryder would eventually end his reality television
stint as the season's runner-up, almost making
the gnarly snake bite worth the trouble.
Like its American counterpart, the British
competition series "Total Wipeout" has its
contestants traverse tricky obstacle courses,
often resulting in them plunging into the
water or mud below.
In addition to its full seasons, the program
aired special episodes with celebrity contestants.
In 2011, comedian Dom Joly tried his hand
at the competition only to walk away … well,
not really walk at all.
While navigating through the special's big
ball obstacle course in Argentina, Joly broke
several bones in his foot.
The painful experience left him in recovery
for three months, though he claimed to The
Mirror that his children were excited about
their father appearing on the show.
The incident didn't put Joly off from future
reality television appearances, however; he
appeared as a contestant during the 2016 season
of "Celebrity Island with Bear Grylls."
The teams competing in "The Amazing Race"
come from a variety of backgrounds, be it
co-workers, friends, couples, or families.
These bonds are tested as the duos endure
some of the strangest, most grueling challenges
around the world to determine which team is
eliminated each week.
"The Amazing Race" Season 14 featured one
father-son team who suffered a notably painful experience.
In a nod to Switzerland — the season premiere's
opening location — the teams were tasked
with carrying four 50-pound cheese wheels
down a hill using a fragile backpack.
Among the participating teams was father-son
duo Mel and Mike White, who quickly discovered
they bit off more than they could chew.
Mel severely pulled his groin during the challenge
and was forced to gingerly transport the cheese
by inching along on his butt with the hefty
dairy product in his lap.
The team would eventually be eliminated in
the sixth episode, but they returned for the
18th season of "The Amazing Race."
For "Survivor" Season 37, the long-running
reality competition show decided to pit perceived
underdogs against overachieving alpha types
in Fiji, subtitling the season "David vs. Goliath."
The very first contestant to be eliminated
was Pat Cusack — one of the designated underdogs
— who left the show three days into filming.
However, in contrast to his fellow contestants,
Pat wasn't voted off the island but instead
departed after suffering a severe spinal injury.
He had to be airlifted from the show.
While the contestants were returning to the
island by boat, the ship was hit hard by a
wave, resulting in Pat hurting his back.
His injury was later diagnosed as spinal compression
deterioration.
Pat's injury wasn't filmed, but the immediate
aftermath was.
Viewers witnessed him experiencing intense
pain as he was immobilized and struggling
to maintain his composure.
Though Pat recovered back home after being
medically evacuated, his early departure made
"Survivor" Season 37 begin on a decidedly
painful note.
Of all the contestants on "The Amazing Race,"
some of the most unflappable are the married
couple Gretchen and Meredith Smith, both of
whom appeared in Season 7.
The Smiths held the distinction of being the
oldest couple to make it to the final tour
on "The Amazing Race" to date, progressing
due to their tight teamwork and stoic resilience.
And the most visible testament to the couple's
endurance and good humor about themselves
occurred when Gretchen experienced a particularly
bloody injury.
As Gretchen and Meredith went on a spelunking
challenge to search for a clue, the former
slipped and cut her face badly in the darkened
cave.
By the time the medics arrived on the scene,
her face was covered with blood.
Even following a pretty gnarly accident, Gretchen
was in good spirits, joking,
"I've been wanting a facelift for a long time."
While she and Meredith may not have won the
race, Gretchen's good-natured reaction to
her injury underscores why the couple was
so memorable compared to their competitors.
The high-stakes world of competitive cheerleading
is explored in the Netflix original reality
series "Cheer," with the first season following
the Navarro College Bulldogs on the national stage.
Traveling from their home campus in Texas
to the National Cheerleading Championship
in Daytona, Florida, the Bulldogs pulled out
all the stops in their bid to win the competition.
But for all the practice that the cheerleaders
underwent to emerge triumphant, one nasty
accident on the mat sidelined a prominent
member of the team.
During the Bulldogs' national championship
performance, their teammate Austin Bayles
hurt his ankle, forcing the rest of the team
to pause their showcase and scramble to find
a replacement.
The injury came after Austin performed a series
of back handsprings, coming down painfully
on his left ankle and forcing him to have
to watch the rest of the team perform from
the sidelines.
Fortunately, the Bulldogs proceeded to win
the 2019 championship title without Austin,
and he wound up transferring to Texas Tech
University the following year.
Season 12 of "Survivor" took place in Panama,
as four tribes competed against each other
on the Pearl Islands to crown the season's
sole survivor.
The winner was Aras Baskauskas, who was voted
sole survivor by his fellow contestants at
the end of the season.
But Aras' final day was not a complete triumph.
On the last day of filming, he suffered a
gruesome injury that resulted in him receiving
stitches before leaving the islands for good.
While celebrating making it to the final day,
Aras and his fellow contestant Danielle DiLorenzo
drank a bottle of champagne together on some
rocks.
While drinking, Aras slipped and fell, dropping
the bottle, which shattered below him before
he fell on top of the broken glass.
He received seven stitches from the attending
medics on the spot after cutting up his hand
and was back before triumphing over Danielle
as the season champion.
"Despite the fact that I made it 39 days,
I feel like my ego has been crushed."
Not all game show fails are physically painful
in nature; the embarrassment of broadcasting
one's ignorance to the world is certainly
excruciating in its own right.
The public humiliation is palpable in a 2022
episode of "Wheel of Fortune," with all three
contestants failing to solve a relatively
simple puzzle — even with virtually all
the letters completed.
And immediately after the episode aired, social
media was in a frenzy, lambasting the show's
contestants' inability to figure out the puzzle.
Trying to solve for the five-word phrase "another
feather in your cap," the three contestants
respond with everything from "another feather
in your hat" to "another feather in your map."
Ultimately, the puzzle was solved, though
it took eight rounds and ten attempts before
the correct answer was finally delivered.
Host Pat Sajak would later defend the contestants'
struggle, remarking that the experience in
solving a puzzle is "different in the studio"
setting.
"How big is Really Really Big Man's kitchen?"
"Eh, really really?"
Of all the dating reality shows on television,
"The Bachelor" is something of a gold standard
for the genre, as contestants vie for the
affection of its eligible lead.
This results in all manner of heartbreak and
humiliation.
The most painfully awkward and heartbreaking
incident on "The Bachelor" to date occurred
after a winner was presumably selected, leading
to a publicly messy breakup after the season concluded.
"The Bachelor" Season 22 unfolded much like
any of the previous seasons, with the cutthroat
competition and dangerous liaisons culminating
in Arie Luyendyk proposing to Becca Kufrin
in the season finale.
Arie quickly recognized that he had made a
mistake, however, appearing in a follow-up
television climax to break up with Becca and
embark on a romance with the season's runner-up
Lauren Burnham instead.
"Bachelor" fans denounced Arie for the public
switch after the season finale.
The idea of using a whole episode broadcast
after the intended finale makes for one of
the most painfully embarrassing breakups in
television history.